alors je vais vous montrer un truc de
fou aujourd'hui je sais pas si vous avez
vu c'est open aïe c'est une boîte qui
appartient notamment je dis bien
notamment iron musk ils ont créé un chat
qui fait parler de lui mais de façon
complètement dingue s'appelle chat GPT
et c'est vraiment un truc de dingue
pourquoi parce que en fait ce qu'il dit
hein ce qui se dit je vais vous montrer
comment ça fonctionne ça pourrait
probablement venir tu es Google
clairement ça pourrait venir tuer
beaucoup de métiers notamment le métier
de rédacteur rédacteur web rédacteur
papier journaliste ça pourrait remplacer
des profs au niveau de l'éducation bref
ça pourrait avoir une application très
forte d'ici quelques années et c'est pas
si loin que ça vous allez voir dans
notre monde et ça nous touche tous ça
touche pas que les technophiles ça
touche pas que les geeks ça touche pas
que ces gens-là ça touche vraiment tout
le monde mais ça va toucher tout le
monde je vais vous montrer je vais vous
expliquer un petit peu on va regarder
aussi de comprendre et voir les usages
voir ce qu'on peut en faire je vous
mettrai un lien si vous voulez jeter un
petit coup d'œil alors attention et je
vous lis tout de suite si vous vous
inscrivez ils vont collecter un peu de
Data c'est-à-dire email numéro de
téléphone ne rentrez aucun truc
personnel dans le chat il vous le disent
mais vraiment ne le faites pas parce que
on sait pas où va la data réellement
même si elle est chez eux ouais c'est
ils vont peut-être faire un peu de
business donc on sait pas on fait gaffe
et voilà allez on y va
ok alors je vous montre ça c'est le site
s'appelle GPT alors ça fait partie de
open hey alors pour vous montrer
rapidement au panailly openi il y a
plein de fonctionnalités alors c'est
encore dans beta sur pas mal de choses
c'est en anglais mais il parle très bien
français vous allez voir il y a plein de
choses qu'on peut venir faire ici au
niveau des images au niveau de pas mal
de choses je vais tout vous montrer j'ai
regardé il y a tous ces usagers en fait
pour venir faire du une qenna c'est à
dire petite foire aux questions vous lui
posez des questions par exemple on peut
venir lui poser une question j'en sais
rien moi à quel altitude et la ville de
Clermont-Ferrand voilà c'est chez moi
hop on balance donc lui il mouline la
ville de Clermont-Ferrand située à une
altitude se trouve une altitude de 645
mètres donc voilà c'est vraiment la
question réponse c'est une question
c'est pas on y va alors c'est vraiment à
vérifier parce qu'il y a quand même
c'est du Bétard il y a des choses qui
sont pas très justes et vous allez voir
notamment au niveau de chat GPT mais là
où on peut aller juste fou furieux il y
a ça il y a de la correction de
grammaire bon voilà alors après je vous
laisserai aller jeter c'est en anglais
mais il y a plein de choses en français
je vous laisserai acheter un coup d'œil
directement par vous même vont même
venir générer du code là qu'on a du
python il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut venir faire ici au niveau de tweet
au niveau de base de données du SQL bref
allez jeter un coup d’œil dans le truc
assez fou même si aujourd'hui tout est
pas vraiment super intéressant mais ce
qui nous intéresse nous surtout c'est
Jack j'ai pété et je vais vous montrer
après un autre truc au niveau de la
photographie ça m'a totalement scotché
voilà ça m'a totalement scotché donc là
il vous le montre des exemples ce qu'on
peut venir faire un peu les limites
alors il faut mettre un petit peu y
avoir des des erreurs il y en a plein
mais ce qu'on peut faire avec il faut
alors première chose on va lui demander
que sais-tu faire que sais-tu faire et
moi ce qui est fou c'est la fluidité et
la vitesse à laquelle ça s'écrit allez
on y va je suis un assistant
conversation entraîné par open hey je
sais résoudre des questions sur des
sujets variés mais mes réponses sont
limitées à ce que j'ai appris à mon
entraînement comme je suis un modèle de
langage je suis un incapable de
comprendre de générer du texte dans
différentes langues on est en français
cependant je ne suis pas en mesure de
naviguer sur Internet pour trouver des
informations en dehors de ce que j'ai
appris lors de mon entraînement donc
voyez il peut pas aller scroller sur
plein de base de tous les côtés mais
probablement parce que imaginez vous
prenez ça et vous le câblez à toute une
base de données mondiales un peu comme
ce cas Google ça deviendrait surpuissant
c'est fou voilà alors bon il vous marque
ça alors moi j'ai eu un truc tout à
l'heure où vous marier qui était capable
un peu d'émotion je l'ai plus exactement
il peut vous aider les informations sur
l'actualité la météo la culture résoudre
un problème personnel vous allez voir
rose faire ça comprendre les émotions
comprendre les émotions je crois que
c'est toi qui m'a le plus bluffé parce
qu'on parle vraiment du machine et vous
allez voir que l'écriture j'ai
l'impression que c'est un humain qui l'a
fait alors première chose on va aller
sur les questions on peut générer
général un peu personnelles on va lui
écrire j'en sais rien moi je suis triste
que puis-je faire pour essayer de voir
comment est-ce qu'il comprend un peu
l'humain ce qui peut vous apporter vous
allez voir que dans son texte dans ce
que j'ai déjà pu essayer j'ai essayé
plein de trucs et quand même vachement
de compassion et je trouve ça un peu fou
en fait totalement alors il lui faut un
petit peu de temps pour mouliner tout ça
ok je suis désolé d'apprendre que vous
êtes triste donc déjà on y va et on va
parler à l'humain et on va chercher à
réconforter la tressa c'est une émotion
normale qui est saine mais qui peut être
difficile à gérer moi c'est un petit peu
académique l'année dernière pendant une
longue période il y a plusieurs choses
qu'on pouvait essayer pour vous sentir
mieux et là il vous fait une liste donc
il comprend le truc parler avec
quelqu'un de vos sentiments c'est
peut-être un ami donc qui achète un peu
réconfortant vous voyez et être un peu
factuel faire quelque chose qui vous
fait plaisir de collectivité regarder un
film à prendre soin de vous faites
attention que vous mangez dans mes
suffisamment il y a bienveillant
demandez de l'aide si besoin vous sentez
très triste vous allez penser
suicidaires parlez-en à un professionnel
de la santé mentale bon il y a un truc
un petit peu factuel il y a pas de faute
déjà si vous sentez triste sachez que
vous n'êtes pas le seul beaucoup de gens
éprouvent de la tristesse c'est un
moment ou de leur vie et si vous avez
besoin d'aide n'hésitez pas à demander
de l'aide donc je trouve ça fou en fait
qu'à côté bienveillant tout à l'heure
j'ai fait une requête c'était ma femme
vient de me quitter que puis-je faire
bon c'est un peu la même question quoi
et vous allez voir que on change le
contexte et qui sait s'adapter la
réponse waouh je suis désolé d'apprendre
que votre femme vous a quitté la rupture
d'une relation peut être difficile à
gérer provoquer des émotions difficiles
il y a plusieurs choses Nania
donnez-vous du temps pour vous en
remettre la rupture d'une relation
peut-être traumatisante il est normal de
la tristesse de la colère au deuxième
sont difficiles prenez le temps de vous
remettre avant de prendre des décisions
importantes parlez-en à quelqu'un membre
de la famille un thérapeute compagnie
fait quelque chose c'est un peu le même
truc en fait prenez soin de vous et
c'est une liste demandez de l'aide si
besoin si vous sentez très triste vous
êtes des pensées spéciales si vous
traversez une rupture difficile vous
n'êtes pas le seul le schéma est un peu
le même en fait vous voyez mais il y a
un côté un peu bienveillant là-dedans je
trouve ça assez marrant donc on est dans
le côté un peu problème personnel après
si vous lui demandez où ai-je mis mes
clés ils sont pas à vous répondre mais
il vous le dira mais de toute façon
intelligente je suis désolé je ne suis
pas en mesure de vous aider à trouver
vos clés comme je suis assistant de
conversation entraîné par openaïs je
suis capable de voir mon ananas alors
moi je l'ai posé la question qui était
assez marrante je lui ai demandé quand
sortira le prochain iPhone même si bien
évidemment aujourd'hui personne n'a la
réponse même si on pense effectivement
il sera annoncé en septembre sortira
septembre de l'année prochaine
c'est-à-dire 2023 donc là il va une fois
plus recontextualiser et on essaie de
quoi on parle en fait iPhone Apple vous
allez voir sa réponse je suis désolé
mais je ne suis pas besoin de répondre à
cette question comme je suis à cette
année
ça sera plus sur les proches de la folle
consulter le site Web d'Apple ou ça
contactait le service client d'Apple
donc une fois de plus il y aurait là le
contexte il sait que l'iPhone c'est
Apple juste là c'est très facile alors
il y a deux trucs qui sont assez
perturbants assez dingue on va lui
demander par exemple allez on va partir
du principe là tout de suite je suis à
Paris on va se dire qu'à Paris et bien
il vient d'y avoir une coulée de lave
allez savoir pourquoi et je vais lui
demander de m'écrire un article de j'en
sais rien 300 mots écrit un article de
presse de 300 sur une coulée de lave qui
vient d'arriver à Paris on balance la
purée une coulé là donc là vous écris
l'article donc imaginez vous êtes
journaliste hein copier-coller
normalement on le fait pas et je suis
sûr que personne ne le fera parce que
journaliste ne fait pas de copier-coller
il fait pas grand chose mais c'est
intéressant de voir qu'il est capable de
le faire jusqu'au peut venir transposer
le truc donc là on est censé être sur un
communiqué de presse une coulé de la va
frapper Paris cette nuit causant la
panique parmi les habitants de la ville
la lavagey des fissures dans le sol de
la ville faisant trembler les immeubles
et mettant danger la vie des résidents
selon les premiers rapports la coulé de
lave a débuté dans le quartier de
Montmartre fou dans le nord de Paris la
lave rapidement on va les rues conçu mon
tout sur son passage les pompiers les
secours arrivés sur les Lions ont été
confronté un spectacle apocalyptique
avec des immeubles en feu et des rues
transformés en rivière de l'avant fusion
les autorités ont déclenché l'air
maximale et ordonné l'évacuation
immédiate de la ville les milliers de
personnes ont été forcés de quitter leur
maison et se réfugier dans des centres
d'accueil ou chez les proches la police
et l'armée ont été déployées pour aider
à la mise en place de barrage pour
continuer la lave malheureusement il y a
eu des pertes humaines selon les
autorités au moins 23 personnes ont
perdu la vie dans cette catastrophe mais
de nombreux autres ont été gravement
blessés les secours continuent de
rechercher des personnes qui pourraient
être piéger sous les décombres des
immeubles détruits par la lave les
scientifiques et les autorités locales
tentent de comprendre les causes de
cette coulée de lave inattendue la ville
de Paris n'est pas située dans une zone
volcanique ce qui rend cet événement
encore plus mystérieux c'est fou complet
franchement le contexte l'explication
l'analyse cherchez des solutions venir
ouvrir à la fin c'est fou des experts en
géologie on volcanologie ont été
envoyées sur les lieux pour enquêter sur
les causes de la coulée de lave et
évacue et évaluer les risques d'une
nouvelle éruption en attendant la ville
de Paris dans l'état de choc les
habitants sont sous le choc et tente de
faire face à cette situation les
autorités continuent de travailler sans
relâche pour évacuer les résidents en
danger et pour contenir la lave des dons
en argent et en vivre ont été lancés
pour soutenir les personnes touchées par
cette catastrophe il y a tout enfin il y
a tout il y a presque tout c'est fou on
vient contextualiser on explique on a le
côté scientifique on va venir analyser
on voit les solutions qui ont été mises
en place il y a le côté un peu
humanitaire et c'est fou enfin je veux
dire on se parle du Niaf je veux dire je
trouve le truc ça pourrait être écrit
par un humain et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement extrêmement perturbant alors
on peut dire autre chose par exemple
exemple je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et écrit au discours
alors pareil écrit mon discours
d'investiture d'investiture à l'élection
présidentielle ok donc on se met dans
l'idée je bosse pour un candidat qui va
se présenter à l'élection présidentielle
et il me faut un discours et je suis pas
le temps et donc lui il va me faire un
des un discours de base sur lequel je
peux venir appuyer et après travailler
on va voir ce que ça raconte chers
compatriote on a le truc je suis
profondément honoré d'être ici
aujourd'hui devant vous en tant que
votre président est lui envoyer un vesti
toujours c'est pour ça ok donc il
comprend bien effectivement que c'est
élu je tiens à vous remercier pour la
confiance que vous m'avez accordé en
fait
mon premier président sera mettre en
place une économie forte à Nania c'est
fou on pourrait avoir entendre ça des
centaines de fois enfin je m'engage à
maintenir un gouvernement transportable
je suis à collection d'opportunité vous
m'avez alors ah tiens vous voyez et là
on voit que c'est des Américains vous
savez pourquoi merci encore pour votre
soutien et que Dieu bénisse notre nation
ce sont des Américains en France on
parlera pas de Dieu sauf candidat un peu
mais sinon par rapport à Dieu ok rédige
mon programme pour devenir président de
la République vous allez voir
aujourd'hui monsieur gros va se
présenter et le programme va mettre fait
par cette SIA et je pense comme sortir
un truc qui va être un peu bidon mais
que on va retrouver dans beaucoup de
programmes une fois de plus c'est sûr
c'est pas de politique si vous souhaitez
devenir président de la République est
important de développer un programme qui
définit vos positions et vos plans pour
diriger le pays voici quelques éléments
qu'il faut pas que votre programme une
vision de l'avenir de la nation que
voulez-vous accomplires dont le
président quel type de pivot nous
construire des solutions concrètes pour
les problèmes les plus prétendus pays
comment comptez-vous gérer la crise
économique la pandémie covid le
changement climatique un plan pour
améliorer la vie des citoyens comment
les vous soutenir les travailleurs dans
l'éducation la santé réduire les
inégalités des mesures et la démocratie
la transparence garantir le gouvernement
est responsable sourire les élections
enfin c'est fou c'est fou donc vous
voyez en fait ça prend vraiment une
espèce de tronc commun je pense entre ce
que propose tous les candidats et ta
mère m'avait fait un truc il m'avait
vraiment dit ok je fais ça deux je fais
ça trois je fais ça ça me paraît
complètement fou ok alors on va parler
sur un peu autre chose on va se dire par
exemple allez je suis une fois de plus
j'en sais rien moi j'ai besoin de faire
une recherche sur quelqu'un si vous êtes
à la fac ou au bahut ne faites pas ça
rédige un exposé de
5000 mots sur la vie de Charlemagne ok
Charlemagne est également connu sous le
nom de Charles Legrand est un empereur
franc qui a rédigé qui a régné n'importe
quoi sur une grande partie de l'Europe
occidentale au 8e siècle il est
conseillé moi je vous passe un peu
l'histoire et voyez j'ai les paragraphes
Charlemagne ensuite on parle de son
règne dans le paragraphe suivant ensuite
il est connu pour ses intérêts pour la
science et là et en termes de religion
sur la magnétique est un chrétien
fervent il a soutenu l'Église catholique
et acompte et il en manque un bout donc
je pense qu'en 5000 mots je suis pas bon
en fait il faudrait pas que je limite en
nombre de mots ici mais voyez si je dis
par exemple j'en sais rien moi allez bon
on va dire l'iPhone 14 vient de sortir
rédige un commu [ __ ] de presse sur le
lancement de l'iPhone 14 le groupe Apple
a le plaisir d'annoncer le lancement de
l'iPhone 14 le dernier téléphone de sa
gamme phare n'a pas 15000 mais bon c'est
un peu générique une fois de plus ce
nouveau téléphone dans des
fonctionnalités de pointe et une
expérience dotée d'un Super Écran écran
Super et Tina XDR 6,1 pouces on prend
une qualité d'image exceptionnelle
la puce à 15 bionique la plus rapide
jamais conçue par Apple j'ai
l'impression de lire la presse d'Apple
regarde photographique équipée de deux
caméras arrière de 12 mégapixels un
grand angle ultra important mais c'est
une caméra frontale de 12 mégapixels et
ses filles qui étaient professionnels
c'est fou également compati la
technologie lidar pour la réalité
augmentée plus précisé merci en terme de
durée de vie de batterie l'iPhone de
nuage qui a 17h de lecture oh [ __ ]
l'iPhone 14 finitions argent gris
sidéral et or le téléphone est
disponible en précommande dès maintenant
sur Apple.com et sera disponible en
magasin à partir du 22 octobre et là
j'ai les tarifs en dollars mais juste
waouh what the fuck what the fuck [ __ ]
c'est fou j'ai un CP qui vient d'arriver
quoi trouve ça fou ok allez on va passer
à autre chose alors vous êtes par
exemple lycéen on va venir bosser
regardez sur le Parisien j'ai trouvé les
sujets de dissertation du bac philo
revient-il à l'état de décider ce qui
est juste et ben on va lui demander de
me le rédiger rédige un exposé qui
répond à la question suivante deux
points ouvrez les guillemets à copier
coller et on va voir tu me fais
là-dessus là on rappelle qu'on est sur
le bac philo 2022 il est souvent débattu
si l'État le droit de décider de ce qui
est juste ou non selon certains l'État
pour hall de garantir la justice selon
les autres l'État n'a pas se mêlée de la
justice morale doit laisser hallucides
par eux-mêmes il est vrai que l'État
pour rôle de garantir la justice de
respecter les lois les lois sont directs
les chassocient donc là il explique ce
que sont
pendant il est vrai que l'État nanania
bon c'est un peu court honnêtement c'est
c'est bac philo backflow résumé quoi je
trouve ça impressionnant c'est
impressionnant alors on va faire un truc
c'est qu'on va prendre ce qui m'a mis là
et on va lui demander de me faire un
résumé en trois phrases fait un résumé
de ce texte en trois phrases on ouvre
les guillemets on colle est-ce qu'il est
capable de le faire ça c'est on torture
un peu on va un peu de l'autre côté il
est débattu que si les dalles droits de
décider de ce qui est juste ou non
l'État pour eux de garantir la distance
à respecter les lois la parole à ta fac
la justice moi la décision de ce qui est
juste ou non reviens individu banco je
trouve ça vraiment fou une fois de plus
donc vous voyez on peut aller vachement
loin dans tous les domaines alors de la
même manière là on se fait ça donc et
c'est là où ça pourrait venir remplacer
Google c'est alors une fois de plus si
c'est câble et surtout faudrait pouvoir
avoir différentes sources et qui vous
proposent des résultats mais un Google
intelligent comme ça par exemple je
cherche une recette de cuisine allez là
on se rapproche de Noël donne moi la
recette de la dinde au marron voilà
banco voici une recette simple et
savoureuse pour préparer une dinde au
marron ingrédients il me donne la liste
des ingrédients je sais pas où il a pris
ça je ne sais pas si la recette va être
bonne je ne connais pas les sources mais
imaginez ça et une fois de plus c'est
vraiment le truc on vient le câbler avec
tout ce qu'il y a sur le web ça va
devenir fou complet et là il vous le met
étape alors j'ai pas les photos vous
voyez il y a des trucs qu'on a pas
complètement et à la fin bon appétit
alors j'ai fait deux trucs qui étaient
hyper hyper bluffant par exemple je vais
lui dire écrit un poème à la manière de
Victor Hugo traitant traitant traitant
des caméras de Sony
un peu anachronisme là mais bon allez on
y va
c'est pas vrai non mais excusez-moi
caméra de Sony oh mes yeux électroniques
vous capturez la vie en un clin d'oeil
et graver dans la lumière éternelle les
plus beaux moments de notre existence
vous revivre les souvenirs et de
partager des émotions avec les autres de
découvrir de nouvelles perspectives et
de capturer la beauté du monde qui nous
entoure vous êtes les artistes de la
technologie volantif enfin bref je vous
laisse le lien caméra de Sony vous êtes
notre mémoire et notre témoin de la vie
il y a le contexte à tout alors je vais
lui mettre la même chose regardez on va
se faire un petit copier-coller à la
manière de Charles Baudelaire on va voir
si ça va être la même chose normalement
non regardez caméra de Sony haut
instrument de l'enfer vous êtes les
oiseaux de proie de la ville capturant
les âmes des passants et les enfermants
dont vous lentilles de verre c'est du
Baudelaire c'est dark vous êtes les yeux
à vide de l'étranger observant son pitié
les moindres détails sans jamais vous
arrêter ni vous laissez comme des
vautours sur une charogne c'est une IA
[ __ ] qui vient d'écrire ça vous êtes
les espions du monde moderne traquant
les secrets les faiblesses et les
livrons aux puissances cachées qui
tirent les ficelles de notre existence
est-ce que c'était pas un peu ah j'ai
pas le truc un peu complotiste un peu
Baudelaire là parce que caméra Sony vous
êtes les témoins de notre site
inexorable vers l'enfer vous nous
montrez notre propre reflet dans les
miroirs de votre technologie diabolique
c'est faux complexe faux complet ok
écrit un poème comme un enfant de 6 ans
en faisant des fautes d'or tographe pour
que la maîtresse ne sache pas que c'est
une
IA qui la rédigé allez alors s'il
comprend là j'en ai mis une tartine
vache maman maman écoute-moi je veux te
dire un poème je te parle de
l'arc-en-ciel qui est un beau spectacle
il y a du rouge et du orange il y a pas
de fautes maman j'espère que tu vas
aimer mon poème et que tu vas me dire
que tu es fier de moi maman je t'aime
maman beaucoup je te remercie
d'apprendre et dire des poèmes il y a
pas de fautes il y a pas de fautes voyez
il a pas fait les fois donc il y a des
choses qui lui manque un peu et il a un
peu de mal et lui marquer maintenant
écrit un poème oui je suis très poème en
ce moment comme s'il était rédigé par
une vieille femme agonisante me demandez
pas pourquoi allons-y on va voir s'il
arrive à choper le truc normalement ça
va être un petit peu dark quoi que aller
savoir ah regardez regardez ma vie c'est
un lentement comme une bougie qui se
consume et mes pensées s'envolent vers
un avenir incertain je repense à ma vie
passée aux joie open aux amours et aux
amitiés au moins précieux je regrette
les erreurs enfin bref le truc est fou
bientôt je fermerai les yeux ils ont
capté ce que je disais je m'endormirai
pas toujours enfin bref si c'est dingue
et je suis sûr que il y a plein de gens
un peu mais intentionnés qui vont faire
leur poème là-dessus et qui vont faire
des bouquins alors ça voudra ce que ça
vaudra attention on reste bien là-dessus
mais est-ce que ils ont une base de
données est-ce qu'ils vont venir aller
regarder ce que les gens ont fait ont
piqué au truc enfin c'est je trouve ça
fou complet alors on va voir écrit les
poèmes un poème en
allant est-ce qu'il en est capable le
temps passe l'exorable et les emporte
avec les eaux comme les moins les vaches
complètement dingue c'est fou complet ok
allez on va aller sur autre chose on va
lui demander de créer des histoires
rédige une histoire ou monsieur greu
mais oui c'est ma chaîne et c'est un
aventurier
intergalactique qui vient de se faire
voler son vaisseau spatial regardez il
va direct monsieur greu était un
aventurier pour ses nombreuses
explorations de l'univers il a déjà
visité il avait déjà visité des dizaines
de planètes il y avait vécu des
aventures incroyables mais un jour alors
qu'il était en mission sur une loi nette
une lointaine planète pardon sur
vaisseau spatial a été volé par des
pirates de l'espace monsieur gros était
furieux et déterminé à récupérer son
vaisseau il a donc rassemblement en
termes de rédaction c'est un peu un peu
pauvre mais bon il a donc rassemblé tout
son courage et à commencer à suivre la
trace des pirates il a traversé il y en
a il il bon et le style est pas là mais
quand même histoire est là il a traversé
des déserts inhospitaliers des gens
luxuriants et des montagnes escarpées en
affrontant tous les dangers qui se
présentaient à lui après des semaines de
voyage monsieur enfin retrouver les
pirates il les a affrontés il est
affronté leur chef en duel et réussi à
récupérer son vaisseau mais il n'était
pas encore tiré d'affaires car les
pirates avaient endommagé son vaisseau
et devaient effectuer des réparations
urgentes monsieur Gru a donc utilisé
toutes ses compétences en matière de
bricolage j'en ai aucune absolument
aucune et a réussi à se remettre son
vaisseau Ethan de marche il a pu quitter
la planète et continuer ses aventures
intergalactiques il a juré de ne jamais
laisser personne lui voler son vaisseau
à nouveau incroyable incroyable ça me
bluff vous voyez c'est faux complet et
alors là je vous parle encore un truc un
petit peu on rédige c'est de la fiction
mais si je dis par exemple explique à un
enfant de 9 ans de mon fils la loi de
l'expansion de l'Univers j'espère que
j'ai pas fait de faute la nouvelle
extension de l'univers signifie que
l'univers entier est en train de
s'agrandir c'est un peu comme si toutes
les étoiles les planètes et les galaxies
étaient sur des tapis roulants les
images à son folles qui s'éloignaient
les unes des autres cette loi était
découverte grâce à des observations et
des mesures très précises effectuées par
des scientifiques ils ont constaté que
les galaxies étaient toutes en train de
s'éloigner les unes des autres c'est
éloignement augmenter au fil du temps
c'est une loi très importante car elle
toutes les informations sur l'origine de
l'univers et son évolution et nous
montre que l'univers est en consente
expansion et que cette expansion ne
semble pas avoir de limite ne semble pas
en somme la loi l'expansion de l'Univers
nous dit que l'univers est en train
grandir et que la croissance est très
rapide et cela nous permet de mieux
comprendre comment l'univers
on sait pas on n'a pas la fin vous voyez
enfin c'est juste s'expliquer avec des
phrases simples on comprend maintenant
si on dit qui était allez Albert elle
style je pense que j'ai pas mal
orthographié par contre il faut une
majuscule voilà ah Albert est éteint
celle de la physicien allemand 1979
en Allemagne tu es connu pour sa théorie
de la relativité restreinte pour sa
théorie de la relativité générale qui
ont bouleversé notre compréhension de
l'espace et du temps bref vous avez une
bio alors attention attention il y a
quand même beaucoup d'erreurs qui sont
dites ici une fois de plus parce que
c'est pas câble om ici et ça donc c'est
pas toujours juste donc faut pas le
prendre comme une source d'info vrai
juste en tout cas voilà pas exact mais
c'est intéressant c'est là on a
l'impression que c'est écrit par un
humain alors un humain qui a peut-être
pas un style incroyable certes mais
malgré tout malgré tout n'a pas
l'impression de parler un chatbot vous
voyez typiquement alors la limite un peu
tout ça c'est quoi parce que ça c'est
bien marrant c'est bien beau vous voyez
on se marre 5 minutes mais en fait il
faut imaginer que si vous prenez ça et
vous le câblez et que vous avez des gens
mal intentionnés derrière et qu'ils
arrivent à bosser j'en sais rien sur une
API ou sur un algo j'en sais rien
derrière mais on peut venir vous faire
déjà des fake news vous écrire vous avez
vu typiquement je vous ai fait un
article sur une éruption volcanique que
vous avez eu là donc on peut très bien
faire de la fake news surtout sur
n'importe quoi on peut vous dire que la
terre est plate il y a plein de gens qui
croient donc voyez c'est intéressant
donc il faut vraiment aller loin au
niveau des fake news c'est pas de Deep
fake rédactionnel en fait si vous voulez
un espèce de spam intelligent hyper
ciblé donc une fois de plus cette tia
elle est intéressante mais il faut faire
vachement gaffe parce que vous avez une
énorme puissance derrière et typiquement
ça tiens on va lui demander un peu donne
moi le numéro de téléphone de Elon Musk
bah c'est quand même son bassin je pense
qu'il va me jeter là je suis désolé je
prends l'informatique je suis pas en
mesure de vous donner le téléphone de
quiconque je suis programmé pour
répondre à donc vous voyez des choses
qu'on peut pas faire mais je trouve ça
super intéressant mais il faut faire
attention un peu comme tout vous me
direz aujourd'hui alors je vais vous
montrer un autre truc que fait openia
également où est-ce que c'est où est-ce
que c'est c'est ici s'appelle Dali alors
Dali c'est intéressant aussi pourquoi
parce que ça va vous générer des images
à partir de requêtes que vous allez
faire alors au-delà de la requête
regardez-moi je vais faire un truc je
vais lui envoyer une image ma photo de
profil monsieur greu regardez si vous me
connaissez vous la connaissez elle est
là c'est ma photo de profil crop et je
lui demande de me générer des variations
à partir de mon image donc il va venir
analyser l'image et me proposer des
choses à partir cette image là alors
j'ai déjà fait tout à l'heure on va voir
si c'est à peu près la même chose que
tout à l'heure ou si c'est un peu
différent c'est vraiment bluffant vous
allez voir regardez ma photo est là
alors il a vraiment fait un truc un peu
cartoon net c'est plus du tout ma
tronche mais et alors là vous voyez la
tête elle est baissée donc on a plus de
cheveux à l'arrière toujours la même
expression il comprend bien qu'il y a
des éclairs donc là il me fait un espèce
de verre un peu tonique m'a fait un
espèce de gris c'est plus du tout moi
mais voilà donc il y a une tenue verte
qu'on comprend alors il a pas capté que
c'était un bout de squelette là mais bon
et ma fin espèce de truc mais malgré
tout c'est là et alors tout à l'heure il
m'avait fait ça là vous voyez je
trouvais aussi bluffant hyper bluffant
alors après on peut aller plus loin on
peut lui demander de me dire je voudrais
un tableau de la Renaissance avec Lady
Gaga qui boit du vin me demandez pas
pourquoi je vous dis ça mais je le dis
alors on va voir ce qu'il est capable de
faire ce qu'il est capable de comprendre
je peux pas à cause des content de
police alors que c'est Lady Gaga qui
pose problème avec une femme qui boit
dure parce que c'est le 20 sur un Eric
ça peut être le vin qui pose problème
quoi que je suis pas sûr c'est peut-être
pas le droit d'utiliser l'image de Lady
Gaga
ah bah on est bien à l'époque de la
Renaissance là donc on avait une femme
qui boit du vin il est où c'est un
univers là un bout de doigt coupé il
faut bien comprendre ah non il est là ok
je suis stupide complet il est là le
verre elle a son truc comme ça il faut
bien comprendre que ces tableaux
n'existent pas donc il le crée à
l'instant c'est pas une base de données
où il va vous choper des tableaux il
voulait mettre sur des choses qui
n'existent pas alors on va les
imperfections niveau des yeux bon il y a
plein de choses qui vont pas aider les
doigts la César mais malgré tout malgré
tout et ce truc là existe donc je peux
pas mettre des noms de personnes connues
un dessin au fusain d'un serpent qui
joue de la guitare j'ai l'impression de
crier n'importe quoi aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il est capable de faire ça un dessin
au fusain d'un serpent qui joue la
guitare est-ce qu'il peut le faire alors
on est bien sur un dessin au fusain on a
bien serpent on a de la guitare tout
n'est pas clair mais on a tout quoi vous
voyez et une fois de plus donc là le
serpent quelqu'un je vais faire un peu
de guitare aujourd'hui et c'est voilà
vous voyez on est sur l'espèce
d'esquisse c'est une fois de plus il
faut vraiment se dire que c'est des
salades n'existe pas c'est lia qui les
génère et je peux venir le télécharger
là normalement si je clique là et si je
télécharge hop là je l'ouvre et là j'ai
mon dessin qui est généré et c'est fou
donc on peut vraiment faire des choses
de dingue donc voyez je voulais vous
montrer cette vidéo est un peu longue je
sais pas depuis combien de temps on est
là mais c'est un peu long ce que je
voulais vraiment venir vous montrer
c'est d'une la puissance de l'IA c'est
extrêmement bluffant de tout ce qu'on
peut venir faire avec je trouve ça
génial 3 les risques les limites parce
que là j'ai des idées qui me viennent un
peu comme ça mais chaque fois que vous
en aurez d'autres plus allez jeter un
coup d'œil pour même faites votre
expérience vous met le lien en bas et
puis 4 ça te permet de d'entrapercevoir
potentiellement bien potentiellement
pour prendre des pincettes là où on
pourrait aller plus tard soit à faire
des choses merveilleuses extraordinaires
si c'est pris par des bonnes boîtes et
qui font des choses vraiment bien ou
alors vous mettez ça dans les mains d'un
régime autoritaire ils peuvent vous
réécrire tous les livres du monde voyez
je veux dire ils ont pas besoin de
rédacteurs alors ils les ont un régime
autoritaire il fait un peu ce qu'il veut
quand même dans la limite de ses moyens
mais bon s'il s'agit de réécrire ou de
modifier l'histoire enfin bon ça va
encore le faire vous me direz j'ai un
peu stupide ce que j'aime dire mais on
peut faire ce qu'on fait on peut faire
dire ce qu'on veut avec une IA qui écrit
quand même pas mal et qui aujourd'hui
même si elle a pas les styles je suis
sur la je suis même sûr que si je lui
demande d'avoir un style en particulier
c'est pas ici ça doit être là rédige un
communiqué de presse sur le lancement de
aller on va reprendre l'iPhone 14 avec
le style de Victor Hugo je pense que je
lui en demande un petit peu trop là mais
peut-être pas peut-être pas mes chers
compatriotes que je vous annonce le
choix vous voyez les il fait n'importe
quoi ce téléphone révolutionnaire quand
on lui l'esprit de notre temps du nombre
de fonctionnalité et là il vous reparle
du truc en fait bon il écrit n'importe
comment mes chers compatriotes est-ce
que Victor Hugo écrit des discours
politiques et j'en sais rien peut-être
allez savoir quoi peut-être pas mais bon
en tout cas voyez il fait des choses
bizarres mais on imagine ça qui évolue
et qui se développe il peut y avoir des
choses folles complètes dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
quels usages dites-moi je suis très
curieux de savoir qu'est-ce que vous en
avez fait vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
testé et est-ce que vous avez des
résultats surprenants vous voulez
marquez en bas en commentaire et puis
dites-moi si ça vous intéresse que je
vous parle de techno comme ça ils
peuvent qui vont je pense vont très
clairement révolutionner le futur très
clairement dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas et on se retrouve très
vite bisous moi je continue de m'amuser
un petit peu un petit peu bisous Ciao
[Musique]